hi i'm ryan i'm leilani and we're gonna
watch the trailer today two trailers
that's right it's a double whammy today
we're gonna watch the trailers for
nymphomaniac part 1 and part 2
back-to-back both volumes full movie
trailer that's what we're doing
and I was just telling Leilani about by
the way Leilani first Asian girl to have
on the channel this is pretty awesome
this is pretty awesome dick you know
that's my thing bringing girls on and it
makes me look cool Thank You Leilani
you're doing a great job
oh yeah sign her about it she was having
the the most intrigued reaction I've
ever seen cuz everyone knows Shia
LaBeouf has sex in this film even though
the shot of the penis in the vagina is
not his penis which is very
disappointing information wouldn't you
want to see Shia LaBeouf's actual penis
yes absolutely that's what people would
want to see so why didn't they deliver
on that damn anyway sure he has a
wonderful erection really excited you
should be this is the most awesome thing
you hear but that's a lot I don't want
to give you the wrong impression now
like I'm I just swear I'm not like I'm
just okay
that's the bye bye God that you're a
huge Hornet no you're not okay all right
here we go one two three time to get our
sex addiction off
see that mature no should have in China
[Music]
my fly
that's how I lost my virginity Kayla is
pretty sexy he does yeah we see
synthetic
[Music]
one yeah new do you mean if I showed you
was that human Thurmond yeah
tomorrow see some sex this is so awkward
to be in that position you're
uncomfortable actually
but how they're really going all out
with this movie disturbing
[Music]
coming soon that's what it said coming
it was they spelled it wrong
no I wasn't making a sexy playboy woman
and their brains do not catch on I was
doing awesome humor that was mine alone
for a second I couldn't like now we're
gonna watch part 2 part 2
I don't really know apart ones about me
but my chest is still like I think
merits being bad is it
Wow so you've never seen anything like
that no no you've never come across like
a more insight before that wasn't like
porn that was like I was like a movie
with born I was like really dramatic and
intense for me there's some porn like
that
you'd be surprised a lot and so would
you viewers yeah oh yeah I've never seen
yeah I don't think that I don't think
the second trailer is uncensored I think
no no my heart's not racing it's just
like I feel like like the air was like I
want this trailer playing all day on my
computer I feel pumped up ready kill
someone
okay apparently the trailer jack leilani
one two three part two knuckle pea
[Music]
he's crying I love him I didn't love him
as much until this moment oh yes we did
Christian Slater
[Music]
we're gonna get some sexy
[Music]
whose butt was that
it must be the scariest type of sex that
huh
[Music]
the hundred is on a note of the table
that's what happens when she already
hasn't I see something similarly orgasm
alright two black guys yeah the other
one was very clear all motors everyone's
just so funny in this movie yeah yeah
like a dark kind of horny you know I
like a black person good morning I mean
might be particle okay yeah that's very
racist joke I don't like racism but a
good racist joke gets me every time
gets me every time I know if you get
Asian jokes but I'm not gonna say
anything okay
Asian people can dress